okay just a
24.5 challenged me to a game
chest 24 and a half
b3 uh knight f6 g6 knight f6
was initial theater major in college no
but i just have some drama classes my
friend
i was particularly well versed in drama
that's why they called me the drama
queen nope
they did not okay so what do we do
we need one knight on c6
perhaps the other one on d7 what was
your major
i had no major i
only had minors no i didn't have majors
i didn't have minors
if you had drama you can become canada's
next pm
very good at math oh drama that's
wonderful you are an attentive student
drama queen you're playing a turkish guy
i think subway john
okay war and peace or the brothers
karamazov war and peace
hands down i read war and peace without
a pause brothers karamazov i'm still
somewhere in the middle
and i forgot that i was reading them
because i was i was not too entertained
maybe it's because there were brothers
there were like too many of them
maybe if there was one karamazov i would
be able to keep track of him but they
were
a couple so i kind of got bored with
them
also had to differentiate you know there
was one brother then there was the other
it's too complex
war and peace was a lot easier that was
the word that was the piece you know
there were no siblings involved okay so
d6
okay
what would you be doing right now he
would suck a chest
i would suck a chest
if i would suck a chest right now i
would definitely suck a chest so
um i did give you an education somebody
says
when vavaches is still obsessed with his
own clips
sir please let it go
please let that go sir
a5 a3 a5 very nice guys you see how
quinos 5 is sitting nicely tight there
on c5
nicely tied it has not many squares but
it does not need many squares
i meant what do you think would be your
profession oh really
oh thanks for clarifying because that
was really confusing wording of that
question
oh you mean what would be my profession
okay wow
okay well my profession
how bad is your eyes side
okay b4 can't i can i not take twice
what do you think you wanka
i'll just snatch that phone there next
to the other white phone
yeah i think it's looking very beautiful
and black's control of the squares in
the center
that one up there the dark one and the
one left
down from it nice extra pawns i think
he's gonna do it but we have to wait and
see
oh
okay um f5
queen t5 okay let's play with d8
do you eat bread generally curious yeah
i eat bread
and now what did that make me a smaller
person in your eyes
oh he eats bread
he's so inconsiderate of the environment
probably from the plastic packages as
well oh
i never liked the guy but now i know he
is bread
okay naruto